I about a year and a half ago uh I got a
call and I got an offer for u a job and
um I I it was you know a decent enough
offer that I needed to to read it and so
or read read enough of it to know
whether it was going to be any good or
not it had a really funky title it was
called zaroo zaro I I have a feeling
zombies are in this movie yeah okay I'm
smart and zaru shot in Australia
kangaroo zombies there you go okay so I
looked at the title I was like ah [__]
this [__] shark NATO you know blah blah
blah zaroo yeah ridiculous right so I
started reading the script and I [__]
sat I read the script in one sitting I'm
like that this this script has got good
structure this script this and the
character I liked the character I liked
a lot the whole thing needed some work
but I thought like well it's kind of
good so I I read it again and I read it
again and I um thought like it's good
script so um I told them I was
interested I started getting into
contact with the
filmmaker uh Ryan and his partner
Richard and Jud was the producer and we
um you know we started working on the
script we started working on the script
and I'm good at that I'm very very very
good at helping filmmakers make scenes
better make characters better make
things make more sense uh [__] meter
you know like like that doesn't work
this doesn't make sense why you and they
here's the thing and this is what here's
the thing is Richard and Ryan who were
Partners uh and they wrote the script
together they listened to me they didn't
hold on to their script like it was gold
or something most people do that [__]
this guy I don't want to deal with it
yes absolutely that's what happened to
me in Thailand they told me in in
Thailand oh yeah we're very interested
in being collaborative as far as the
script weren I went over there and they
you know um they they just weren't but
these guys did these guys did and so
they listened to me a lot so I was
really able to create the character that
I and it was like I said it was a pretty
good script and first of all I said you
got to change the title I mean unless
you want to do shark NATO you know you
can't call zra that's ridiculous yeah
it's called the red which is much better
it's about well the red is the biggest
uh kangaroo in Australia so they get to
be about six seven feet five or six feet
anyway right and you know kangaroos if
you Google nasty looking kangaroos just
ones that aren't even in movies they're
they're [__] some nasty looking
kangaroos Who Stare right at you they're
all buff they're all they look like
they've been lifting
weights or is that koala KO that's
koalas but they so anyway we you know we
started um talking about it and uh they
they they they sh they were going to
shoot at on location in Australia they
put an Australian U crew together in a
cast and uh then some like torrential
rains hit it you know and it it got
pushed back and I was in Australia at
that point that's why I went to go do
the thing in Thailand I went to do the
thing in Thailand and I came back to do
this
and um but you know I think they lost a
lot of their B A lot of the budget was
lost because you know these these rains
hit and they they had it all cast and
everything and then they had to turn
around and recast it and um so anyway
you finished the movie yeah yeah we did
the movie but Michael it it it was so by
the time that we were shooting it the
budget was so small I mean this is a
monster where you could have spent $20
million on it okay um the budget was
minuscule I mean minuscule there are
times that you would look at the lunch
table you know at night we sh a lot at
nights and there would be the director
his partner Richard the writer uh
talking to him about shots they need to
get a DP his name is uh uh Bland W I
think of his first name I called well I
started calling him blonde
blond I thought his name was blonde and
then I started calling him Blondie and
then I was started start
Blondie you know from the Clint Eastwood
movies but there's only a few people at
this table uh lunch yeah like seven and
you're used to I mean you've done huge
no listen listen when I did I did um
earlier this year before the writers
went out I did a law and order right and
worked um uh with Maloney uh Christopher
Maloney he's he's awesome by the way
what a horse he is what a what a you
know he has that 40 40 Teamsters on that
show okay 40 Teamsters are working on
that show we had like you know we had uh
the guy the DP shot at himself and it
was just him no gaffer uh kind of kind
of yeah not a lot somebody holding one
of their screen no no doesn't seem like
there were any lights out there they
would just hold up screen and it wasn't
frustrating to you no man I had a great
character I you know it was like it was
a great fun character crazy crazier than
a [__] loon um but you know I'm good
at crazy